generating my question at what age did
you start to like realize I wasn't
taught all of this stuff in school where
um you know I'd known that the British
colonies were [__] massive didn't
know why the British museum had all of
like the artifacts from all over the
world that would never returned you know
that was just something that was just
not taught in school about like well I I
remember we just spawned there yeah yeah
it was just like oh must love our
kingdom Kingdom so much that's why
they kiss all of them yeah that's what
they're gifting us all of these things
and we're just putting it on display and
uh that's just a part of History man I
remember we were in we were in school
and uh I took history at a level yeah I
love history I've always been really
fascinated by history
um and we were learning about how the UK
uh was trying to have influence on China
was trying to take over and obviously in
China back when the Hong Kong and all
that stuff yeah uh and China was
refusing to buy any more opium from oh
the European Wars yeah yeah yeah and
they were like
we got all these puppies seeds we gotta
make oh you gotta sell it and so they
just started smuggling it in and getting
people hooked on opium and I head I was
like I was like 16 this time I was like
ah that doesn't sound like something the
good guys would do
not to be that guy but I don't remember
Superman drugging half a country just to
move some product that sounds like some
breaking badass [__] that the bad guys
would do I I maybe I'm crazy hear me out
and then they were like and then they
were like yes we they had to they sailed
these steamboats up that could just
destroy everything and the Chinese uh
Army could only just push barges on fire
in the hopes they would hit them I was
like
that's been Fair
uh yeah it just seemed like I was like
huh there's more to this history thing I
think that started like you know we'd go
to history uh class and I would go home
and just research more yeah you know
because Wikipedia would just tell you
the facts straight up and be like well I
mean whatever was sourced it wasn't
always accurate but it would be close
enough tell you what was done you're
like huh well this stuff seems really as
sketchy the British did
oh they built railroads in these
impoverished countries wow oh they built
only railroads to mines and not any
useful ones you can actually use and
they're all [__] in they can't be
maintained and they left and they left
it so fast that it started the Civil War
and there's been War for 50 years you're
like
we didn't do a good job we just founded
the wrong thing or how we like you know
British you know Johnny Harris made a
[__] 9 billion videos about maps in
Brazil and they would just draw random
lines of maps that would cause Wars that
are still going on today yeah
um because we were so smart yeah it's
like well we've definitely caused so
many goddamn problems yeah I mean and
then you skipped out of there and you're
like we've never lost a war I I think
it's a good thing that the internet
exists now because I didn't didn't
really reach my Consciousness before
like the internet because in Orange
because now there's like so much
misinformation that you can read about
everything that's true that's true well
yeah it's like people the fact that
people I mean not to you know could have
that it's very common now people just
believe that certain very very major
historical events didn't happen and that
they can believe that is mind-blowing to
me yeah uh and so
so telling of the power of information
on the internet and how disinformation
and misinformation can be so dangerous
yeah I feel like with with the way the
internet works now with all Freedom of
Information and everything it's kind of
like it feels like we got like the
monkey poor wish oh it's like you want
access to all the information in the
world that sounds amazing all the all
the information in human history
everyone's gonna get smarter but all of
it's wrong
I think some of my like you you really
like I'd say like modern history right
yeah I like modern history I'm like
really into like ancient history like
yeah I remember like I honestly like one
I I got I got into like I guess one of
like
the periods I think is most interesting
is like Chinese history actually yeah
and like Roman history and like you know
ancient Greece and stuff like that well
those are cool because there's like
literal thousands of years that you can
trace back on yeah exactly so much
happen like yeah like Roman history is
like Emperor chadius Maximus through
games and defeated the Persians and and
then like Chinese history
I mean it kind of kind of feels like
that you know
and then like Chinese history is just so
my firstborn Spanish history is like so
weird because it's like the amount of
times that China's just been broken up
as like a [__] country it's just like
oh there was a minor dispute about the
Farmland somewhere in China 70 trillion
people died in this war also the war
last 500 years I'm like what the [__]
was that and then they all came back
together and held hands and then they
came back together for one year and then
it broke up again and I'm like what what
the [__] is going on yeah it's it's yeah
history I feel like I've only gotten
more interested in history as I've grown
older I don't know I don't know if this
is an age thing because personally you
realize the most interesting [__] that
you can conceive of yeah is just all in
real life and has happened at one point
or busy stories or crazy things people
have done yeah you're like oh my God a
real [__] person did that yeah and I
kind of get I kind of get that feeling
because I feel like a problem is it's
just how boring history is in school I
don't know I thought it was taught in a
very very boring way I thought it was
mad boring yeah like I it didn't I don't
feel like
I don't know for me I always find it
interesting so I found it like it's it's
like looking into another world but a
world that happened and existed and it's
gone did you have a good history teacher
though
um I think he was okay I think I was
just so fascinated in the the thought of
being able to tap into this knowledge of
periods that have gone and yeah that's
the true history yeah I just thought
that was so good like even learning
about like 1950s America felt like so
alien to where we were in the 2000s that
it was like what the [__] I can't
imagine like this time in this place
existing yeah and and learning about
that I found I thought was so cool as a
kid yeah I think to me the reason I
really enjoy ancient history as opposed
to like more like modern histories
because you know I never really found
World War II or like kind of like the
1800s that interesting just because it
felt more tangible than it than like
ancient history so it's closer to our
proxy yeah because like you you still
see like I don't know if the like when
the last World War II veteran is going
to be around for but you know you when I
was growing up there was still like many
War veterans and stuff like that so he
still felt like a tangible thing
um and I don't know I don't know why
maybe it's the escapism part of my mind
where I'm like oh ancient history that's
that's a that's a fake thing that didn't
really happen I I you're treating it
like an Issa guy yeah I know what you
think about how [__] up these dudes
must have been especially dudes because
you forget about it right I think we
always think about World War One World
War II such separate things yeah there's
there's like 30 20 years in between them
yeah yeah you know like
um it was very a good amount of people
who'd served in both yeah how [__] in
the head would you be after going
through that imagine going through it
once and then you're like guys we've got
to do it again yeah what they're just
sitting there all Karma and being like
oh finally it was worth it to come back
and like there's a sequel yeah what's
there's another one especially like the
horrors of like World War One and the
conditions and stuff back then like you
know a lot of a lot of big advancements
were made in medicine and there was like
20 30 years yeah uh between the the two
Wars and also weapons you know oh my God
yeah yeah I mean dude some of the
shooting like all the ones barbaric like
yeah chlorine gas and stuff like like
that like imagine oh my God I mean even
when you look at like the Vietnam War as
well like just some of the [__] that
some of you know the sides were doing to
each other was just like I can't believe
this was in proximity not that long ago
yeah yeah I mean yeah and it's so easy
to think about this happened when our
parents were alive yeah it's crazy it's
so easy to think of those events as like
contained things where it's like a like
a match almost where it's like that was
the game you know and then but those
people do you know how it's so
fascinating to look into how these
people just functioned in society yeah
after there's no war yeah how do you
tell someone who's like 50 years old
who's maybe oh sorry like 60 years old
he's been in world of one and two how
are you like hey so yeah just just love
normally now
learning in the history of that and like
reading accounts of that I think it's
just so fascinating and so cool uh
because it's just like we live in an age
where and the reason why I like kind of
modern history so much is the level of
documentation and different sides you
can get it makes me makes you think like
how maybe ancient history or old history
must have been so biased by like one
source yeah
um no because you get so many different
sources nowadays no it makes me like
I've always found it interesting how you
know you think of
some of the most well-known figures in
some of their fields like I it just like
it's so weird to me to think that you
know [__] there was a time when
Aristotle and Plato were just like
hanging out and [__] like that because
like to me they just they feel like
fictional characters or just like you
know like like you know everyone in the
[__] Renaissance and [__] like that
uh or even just like famous artists like
Picasso and [__] like that you know yeah
you look at like you know some of the
most like famous Renaissance paintings
in the world and you just like look at
and you're like how did one person make
that like that is that is unheard of
like that's that's insane no wonder
they're famous yeah like think about all
the [__] like Leonardo da Vinci did yeah
not just like his paintings but like all
of his inventions and sketches like [__]
didn't he like invent the helicopter
yeah even before he was like one of the
first people to like come up with the
concept of it yeah it's not good it
didn't work but it was a foundation it
was a foundation not good
but one one of my favorite historical
people I've I don't know if I've ever
talked about this I wish it was chattius
Maximus his name should be chadius
Maximus but it was like uh he was like a
philosopher diogenous or is it diogenes
I don't know sorry those I think it
might have never heard of this yeah so
you know Aristotle you know Plato who
has like famous philosophers uh not many
people know about diogenes but he I feel
like he's often he's often called the
father of cynicism and just reading
accounts about all of the [__] that he
got up to it feels like he was the
world's very first troll right okay so
so one one of the things he did so Plato
[__] famous philosopher nowadays his
name is in history every history book
out there so he was apparently having a
lecture
and uh they were trying to Define what
what is a human right what what makes a
human and Plato at the time I believe
called humans featherless bipeds right
uh which which kind of like yeah we're
featherless and we're on two levels yeah
so
diogenese was just like I gotta grade up
I got a great idea so what he does is he
takes the chicken he takes a chicken
plugs all the feathers out walks into
Plato's lecture plops the chicken on the
table and goes behold man
and I and I'm just like I I like you
read accounts of all this [__] I'm just
like this [__] happens we look at
ancient Greece and like you know all of
this time where they fathered philosophy
and all this [__] but I'm just wondering
how much how much troll [__] actually
came down well I mean you know in order
for all of these like amazing
philosophical ideas to actually you know
keep their ground to the point where it
was taught for thousands of years
afterwards in history yeah I mean I'm
sure they went through a ton of trial
and error you know like I'm sure like
for every great idea there was probably
like you know aristol on a bad day being
like so does [__] actually smell bad or
is that just like our perception is huge
let's just
from the history book this is [__]
let's get to the actual good share right
so like I can see why there would have
been philosophers out there like uh
diogenes to just be like yeah let me
just like limit test this like
ridiculous idea that is philosophy yeah
and like see if it actually holds any
ground and I think it's because of
people like that that you know Plato and
Aristotle were like yeah what we said
was legit yeah look at this [__] right
here trying to like prove it